people who have never been in prison has
this perception of when you put up
on the prison bus as soon as you get off
that this is this world mentality
that works if you're looking at somebody
wrong you get stabbed
you get around for your shoes and that's
completely not true
so i did 12 years in prison and most of
it was in corporate state prison my last
three years i didn't sit in the
state prison a lot of people don't know
how to differentiate going to jail
and doing a few days in jail county and
going to prison
during years before you get to prison
you go to a prison reception
and that's like for 90 days and when
them 90 days you're preparing yourself
to go to an actual prison
for the first three days of prison
you're going through your medical
treatment this is where you get your
shots
this is what you get your physical
surprisingly enough
people see the dentist for the first
time when they get to prison
on the fourth day you're gonna go get
your laundry this is your clothes size
your shoe size
everything that's assigned to you and
you're responsible for your
fifth day you can house houses where
you're going to be sleeping at
permanently what building you're going
to be in
but you're still not going to be able to
come out because you got to be clear
to come to new york usually building one
be the orientation building all the new
people
that still need to be seen by the
counselors to see if you have any
gang homies or gang members there on the
same yard as you or any enemies they
can't make sure
they're trying to protect you and the
opposition day six and seven
they letting you go to the yard now
you're in general population you get to
see who your friends are
and who you know some of the top three
mistakes you can make in your first week
going to prison
is borrowing when you borrow stuff it's
about hey man let me get this so i go to
store when you go to store everybody
gets to go to the store once a month
if you have money on your books and then
your store coming you don't have it for
whatever reason
now that man that you borrow from gets
to dictate however how you want to deal
with it
whether you want to do physical violence
you want to double you up and
charge you more or whatever so bars not
good are being disrespectful to somebody
you don't know who
people know or anything like that so you
just don't do it it's not
a whole lot to say about that you just
keep things simple in prison
not trying to go to prisons keeping it
simple if you don't want to go to prison
don't do things that get you to go to
prison
stealing that goes without saying
everybody knows stealing is not good
so you get caught stealing especially in
jail you're going to get dealt with
seriously
i walk prison yards with people never
coming home and they always steal
messages like this to people like me
you know if you ever get a chance to get
out and don't mess up
don't come back these people right there
would love to have
one more chance and we have many chances
out here on the streets
no one should want to lose their freedom
but if you so happens to lose your
freedom and end up in prison
hopefully these tips guide you through
your trials and tribulations
to get you back to your family in your
home
and your loved ones always keep it
simple and always keep it respectful
[Music]
you